bien estuvimos gran parte del año pasado
confinados los meses de desaceleración
económica no bastaron para revertir la
creciente concentración de gases de
efecto invernadero en la atmósfera de
hecho en 2020 la presencia en el aire de
gases que favorecen el aumento de la
temperatura global como el co2 el metano
y el monóxido de nitrógeno alcanzó un
nuevo récord además la agencia
meteorológica de la onu detectó otras
señales preocupantes hay partes de la
amazonía que han cambiado su rol
en
el ecosistema de la selva amazónica que
solía absorber y transformar el co2 se
ha convertido en una fuente de emisiones
de carbono que es alarmante y está
relacionado con la deforestación que
también está cambiando el clima de la
zona aumentando las temperaturas y la
evaporación de
la afe behring evaporación el informe de
la organización meteorológica mundial se
basa en datos sobre la cantidad de gases
de efecto invernadero presentes en la
atmósfera después de que una parte sea
absorbida por los océanos y la biosfera
el reporte llega a días antes del inicio
de la cumbre por el clima con 26 en
glasgow una oportunidad crucial para
concretar los objetivos del acuerdo de
parís de 2015 el acuerdo de parís por el
clima queda aceptado según la agencia de
naciones unidas su informe muestra como
el mundo está lejos de cumplir su meta
de limitar el aumento de la temperatura
global a 15 grados celsius respecto de
la época preindustrial